I help people that others have given up
on they go beyond what medical science
is willing to do because I believe in
hope tell you our dear Rita had been in
an institution for decades after a toxic
gas left herself unstable i freed her
and I'm very thankful chief Larry a
pilot in the Air Force he crashed his
plane and was exposed to a negative
energy he was giving mere days to live
that was over fifty years ago Cliff's
story you're ready now
and finally Garfield he cured me from
what a rare disease he contracted from
an even rarer species of primate in the
Congo Basin although the cure I
administered he had unforeseen side
effects she thinks that I can unzip my
DNA and rearrange it took me a while to
figure it out but that's how he but why
I don't know he thinks it's
psychological
Tigers have always been my favorite ever
since I was a kid go go with them go
have a boy but the chief his back is
broken again we'll take care of him he
helped us car no matter what we owe it
to chief to help him know oh maybe you
guys can come I mean you don't have to
hide anymore
it is what it is kid right you you can
have more than us
[Music]
we're grateful
everybody it's Charlie I got a bunch of
requests to do a video for the Doom
Patrol on Titans so I'll explain that we
also have some news about the flash
filming it's scenes in Wayne Enterprises
for all the Batwoman stuff so we'll talk
about that at the end of the video too
because we're gonna get a trailer for it
really soon so there's a new round of
that DC streaming service giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video we'll talk about Doom Patrol stuff
first then I'll talk about flash
crossover so if you didn't know the Doom
Patrol TV show per this schedule they
released is going to premiere sometime
mid-february maybe right after the
Superbowl right after a Young Justice
airs its first block of 13 episodes so
I'll remind everybody when they start
dropping trailers for that stuff those
are dropping more footage for Young
Justice in December when Titans is
getting ready for its finale
so no worries there but the whole idea
with this is that they're just trying to
give you guards back story as Beast Boy
how everybody got their powers it just
give you a quick once-over this is what
they look like and they're gonna deal
with their character development and
pushing into all those characters when
they get to the actual Doom Patrol
episodes you may have seen some of the
behind the scenes for that but this is
just meant to give you an idea for the
tone of the show and what the characters
feel like there was a really long time
between when they shot this episode and
when they started filming the Doom
Patrol series so I'm assuming they made
a couple minor changes to the characters
in the tone but for the most part it's
these people as well as the cyborg
character that's the only thing you
don't get from this episode is that
cyborg will be a big character he's
played by this actor he'll have a suit
that I think is mostly going to be
practical effects for budgetary purposes
with a little bit of CG like obviously
his eye will have to be CG anytime he
uses energy weapons the clip pretty much
gives you the once-over on how everybody
got their powers negative man is the
only one you don't really see get to use
his abilities you get a little preview
of Alaska girl's powers they play up the
horror angle a little bit more but she
can actually grow really large but
you've all probably seen The Incredibles
and you know what Elastigirl can do on
that the DC version of the character
came decades before the Pixar version of
the character but because everybody seen
Pixar like that's what they're gonna
think when they think Elastigirl
they'll probably just avoid any of those
issues by having people call her Rita
most of the time you probably
that brendan fraiser is playing robot
man is a different actor underneath
there brendan fraiser just as the
voice-over they announced a really big
star-studded cast a while ago but i
didn't know if they were gonna only
include them on the spin-off show or if
they would be featured in this episode
but when I heard them all start talking
I was like oh that's great because
negative man is played by Matt Bomer but
obviously if you have someone that looks
like Matt Bomer you don't want to cover
their face up so it is a little funny
that you have one of the best-looking
actors that you have working on your
show and he's the only one whose face
you never really see but if you're not
really familiar with his powers when the
chief says he was exposed to negative
energy the side effects of that is that
he can astral project a negative energy
form that he can command it can deal all
kinds of damage but he could only be
separated from it for short periods of
time otherwise he'll die and while he's
separated from it his physical form is
completely vulnerable to attack if you
think of them as like a raid group think
of robot man is the tank think of
negative man is their mage like they're
caster squishy mage goes down real quick
but has some of the most powerful
attacks the chief is sort of like one
part mad scientist because he causes a
lot of their problems during the episode
when he won't back off of Raven one part
genius healer so he is a good person but
they kind of want to show you how he's a
little messed up in the head they're all
just a little messed up in the head so
it's a very different kind of superhero
team but the spin-off series is based on
Grant Morrison's Doom Patrol run so if
you want to read up on it that's the run
you should read the villain will be mr.
nobody played by Alan Tudyk so they have
a lot of really big names on this show
yeah Brendan Fraser you have Timothy
Dalton you have Matt Bomer and now Alan
Tudyk
it'll be like 10 to 12 episodes so I'm
sure there'll be plenty of cool guest
stars that'll show up and the Titans
will probably cross over because this is
connected to Titans as you can see from
this episode it's a really big flash
crossover news over in the arrowverse is
that they're in Chicago in real life to
film scenes at Wayne Enterprises for
probably all the Batwoman stuff that's
happening it kind of implies that when
they get to the Batwoman spin-off TV
show her Gotham will double as the
Gotham of the Dark Knight series because
that was shot in Chicago as well so the
architecture will look exactly the same
as it does during Christopher no
Dark Knight trilogy the funny thing
about that is is because you know you
kind of expect a Batwoman show to be in
the same type of tone as arrow a little
bit darker a little more gritty they
turned the city itself into a character
on the show like Gotham is a character
in and of itself within the Batman lore
same thing with Star City on arrow but
the other funny reason why Batwoman is
gonna feel a lot like arrow is is
because both of the shows are Batman
derivatives they're borrowing from the
same material so I wouldn't be surprised
if obviously the coloring and some of
the costumes and the characters are very
different but if the show feels very
much like an arrow type show Stephen
Amell sent a tweet out that made it
sound like he's wrapped all of his
scenes so we'll probably see a trailer
for that in the next couple of weeks but
they've been shooting for a while now
and we haven't really seen a whole lot
of footage of that woman we've seen
behind the scenes pictures I'm assuming
that's because most of her scenes have
been filmed on a studio set behind
closed doors where paparazzi and other
cameras can't get they've been teased in
all kinds of Easter eggs I'm sure then
being in Chicago filming Batman Batwoman
scenes there'll be a lot of Easter eggs
for Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight
trilogy so we'll just keep our eyes
peeled leave all your video requests in
the comments below they'll be more
Marvel and DC posting soon
congratulations to Allen L your the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here for that new flash
trailer and click here to watch the
infinity war cast talk about their
scenes during Avengers 4 thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight